Children before the age of 8 cannot self regulate
without a co regulating caregiver.
And this is where attachment injury is born.
When you hear that,
give your inner child a moment of self empathy and compassion
for the part that can easily come out of regulation.
Because it wasn't your fault.
It simply wasn't your fault.
And it's not your parents fault either
cause they did not know. Who do you think is regulating your child?
They are in daycare or public school.
Who do you think is holding them,
breathing with them, trying to figure out how to regulate their emotion?
If you're wondering why your husband has such a bad temper
or why so many of your exes were completely avoidant
or detached emotionally from your relationship
because they were handed off to daycare workers
and public school teachers
and they were not taught how to properly regulate their emotions,
which has had lasting repercussions on the rest of the relationships
for the rest of their adult life.
I agree with not blaming your parents
because the truth is they didn't know back then.
My mother told me all the time
how the doctors told me
that you guys could go in your own bed at 3 months
and I should let you cry it out.
I know people who would let their children scream for hours
without comforting them because they were told it was right,
either by a parent or a physician.
But now we Have actual data on the Guinea pigs that were us.
As millennials, our generation,
we now know the trauma it causes.
And all the attachment disorders
that I've been discussing in my last 10 videos.
Everything I post, I say out of love,
because I don't want a mom to regret
possibly making the wrong decision with their children.
These are decisions that we can't take back.
And could cause potential trauma for the rest of your child's life.
It is one thing to not know,
but it is another thing to see the evidence,
read the science, read the books,
listen to all these children psychologists
and development psychologists
discussing attachment disorders,
and then to get mad and say that I'm shaming moms.
I'm not trying to shame anyone.
I am trying to make sure you don't get hurt as a mom,
or blame yourself when you are older.
Using to stay home with your child when they are born,
and through the first two years of their development.
It's not a choice to take lightly.
It's not deciding whether you want a Big Mac or a whopper for that day.
This is something that has lasting consequences.
That we are now seeing in every aspect of life in our nation.
Most importantly, should reveal how important your job is as a mother.
It is sanctified, it is beautiful.
It is the most important thing.